mister hale's has been here for 11 days
now outside this combat stress treatment
center in Newport Shropshire this is
your 11th day of fasting isn't it Gus
how are you feeling pretty washed out
pretty tired still lucid still
determined to go to Remembrance Day but
I feel myself getting weaker each day
and you've been sleeping in that tent
behind us how's that been former
paratrooper went through the Falklands
War I quite enjoy it in a strange sort
of way and why did you feel you had to
take these extreme measures lots of
reasons really but we can see that
treatment of veterans returning from
combat is woefully inadequate I think
somebody said there was a suicide last
night which brings the yearly total to
about 57 ah bleed there was 14 in
October and I think it's for this month
November already so the treatment just
doesn't seem to be there doesn't seem to
be together or packaged and that's got
to change its the hundredth anniversary
of the first world war
since shell-shocked was first recognized
today they call it combat related PTSD
and things need to change what do you
want to see change may be dedicated
centers paid for by the government
because it was the government I was
employed by it was the government that
sent me to war and we seemed to be
farmed off to this charity that charity
and the charity sector
I'm sure tries its best but it's it's
not good enough the defence secretary
last week announced 10 million pounds to
go to veteran mental health needs what's
your reaction to that well 10 million
pounds sounds a lot of money but it's
probably the wing of a jet fighter
aircraft so if you're going to send the
to war it cost billions and the war
doesn't just stop on the day of the
ceasefire the guns when the guns go
silent it's continuing war for a veteran
the sights and sounds and smells his
experience will stay with him for the
rest of his life and what ambu symptoms
are you experiencing of course so you've
had an unreserved apology from combat
stress you have for being discharged in
2015 what have been your struggles since
then really after the discharge
I wrote to this organization to ask why
I was discharged still that still
haven't been answered up there's been an
apology but I still don't know why I was
discharged and according to the North's
guidelines this should be a proper care
discharge package which I'm still
waiting for so I don't know where I am
regarding this organization who treated
me for so long I would like a discharge
plan so I can take it perhaps to another
organization say this is what they did
for me this is where I am but although
there's been a unconditional apology I
still have not got that back those
answers now Gus before we go and we must
ask you're breaking your fast on Sunday
what is your message to defense
ministers and the NAD my message is
basically this all the great and the
good will be in white or on somebody in
front of the senator and there's three
words on the senator our glorious dead
what about our glorious living the dead
in many ways we can't do anything for
them we can remember them and that's
what Remembrance Sunday is about but our
glorious living need help they need the
structures and support that when you put
your life on your lion sign up the
country nobody's complaining about that
but please look after them when that
comes to an end and when you break your
fast on Sunday what's it going to be
food-wise I really don't know apparently
sort of calm plans all that
of milkshake very I've got to take it
easy I also get cramps okay well look
after yourself thank you very much for
speaking to us thank you
Oscar said people around the country
will be remembering the fallen on Sunday
and Gus's efforts this week and last
week is for people to remember those who
carry on living with the burden of war